in
so I believe in one or two solutions I
think either one we need to normalize
getting married without the state's
involvement
that would be my first answer or two if
we need the state's involvement we need
to set up license renewals the same way
a driver's license need to be renewed a
gun license needs to be renewed it's
interesting you know I think marriage
license should be renewed and if you
choose not to renew it you shouldn't
need to involve the courts and both
parties should walk away scot-free
wow that's an interesting idea I've
never thought of that
like a license renewal what do you think
should women with the way the laws are
now should they require marriage before
they carry
so yes and no yes that's good advice for
women but no for men
to more liability if I'm being honest
okay so if you had a daughter and she
said I'm with a guy he wants to have
kids in a family but he doesn't want to
get married legally would you tell her
to stay or go
I would tell her to go okay
it's interesting how the advice
conflicts each other
so why why would you tell her to go that
way but it does why would you tell her
to go if you can understand why men
don't want to get married like that
seems reasonable
so I would I would simply tell her to go
because it's going to be in her best
interest now in terms of uh the man
himself obviously I have to meet him and
there would have to be if he thought the
exact same way that I did and I could
relate to him on a person-to-person
level I'm open to exceptions
um but for the most part as a general
rule of thumb just speaking in general I
would advise her to go okay do you think
men
if he loves you he'll marry you do you
think that's true
no I don't think that's true
um I think that he'd be willing to marry
you but it really just depends on the
circumstances in regards to finance in
regards to his perception of the U.S law
um you know there's there's a lot
there's a lot more variables now that we
have social media we have YouTube we
have people like you obviously Kevin
Samuels everybody educating you know
young men I think is going to become
more and more common for men to hesitate
towards marriage
how long do you think is too long for a
girl to be waiting for a ring
yeah I mean it's
um it's tough so if if it's from me
giving the advice to my daughter
um I would say 10 years that's going to
be too long
okay so you'd be okay with your daughter
waiting five
yeah if she's young obviously if she's
in her late 20s and she's gonna have to
uh act a lot more quickly especially if
she wants to have children but yeah I'm
assuming she's young 20 years old 1920
yeah absolutely okay well thank you for
calling in appreciate it
yeah no problem take care thanks you too
the the freaking marriage renewal that
is such an interesting idea
I've never thought this is why I opened
the call lines
because there's stuff I never would have
thought of never would have thought of
that
um
okay guys call and should women marry
before they carry
oh is
um turning your YouTube off in the
background you're live on the air this
is Pearl
hello
okay next color
hello
hi
this is Pearl you're live on the air
what is the solution to Modern dating
going forward for men and for women
oh
my name is James
um
personally I've been viewing things in a
kind of separative situation marriage
has always kind of been overseen by our
government of power so the argument of
removing it from either state or church
is kind of
a misnomer to me
um
but
there is a I believe the problem is
perception
um
we kind of we kind of view marriage as
the defining Act of commitment
and
I think we need to
bring a kind of understanding
of
how
uh commitment and marriage are separate
things because marriage has always been
to support a household or family
um and that changes depending on the
environment that you reside in a the the
age the
um
Nation the culture wherever you are at
that changes what uh the needs of a
group what do you mean can you tell me
more about the difference between
commitment and marriage
well commitment is your is your personal
decision to be committed to one in uh to
an individual or anything and that uh
doesn't have to be that one person
um it
being committed means you're committed
to this thing so if it's a relationship
you're committed to that relationship if
you're committed to your job whatever
it's you're committed to it marriage
um is taking on extra
uh characterizations to support
the things that come along with that so
um if you have a family marriage it
helps you whether it be taxes or
um household environment stability there
are benefits to come with it that's
always been the case with marriage
so what do you think the solution is
going forward should men get married
uh
no the solution I I'm thinking or going
or going for is um to
re re-understand and Define how we view
such relationships and marriages
um
to make it easier to conceptualize and
restore
um the kind of balance it when we have
government involvement because there
always will be in some fashion
government or organization like the
church there'll always be right now it's
all it's war is so one-sided and it's
and it's incentivized to kind of disrupt
it
um
uh disrupt marriage because walking away
for a woman uh comes with so many
benefits right we need to restore
um that one so it's actually
incentivized to maintain a marriage
but also have the perception that
marriage itself is to support
um things to bring in extra extra
benefits and extra
um
Aid that's it's not the defining one
that makes commitment your own choice at
being committed is what defines
commitment marriage is a helping hand in
in a way
um because that's what you're doing when
you get married you're like hey cool
we're married can I have these benefits
you know do you think women should marry
before they carry
foreign
logical to fully expect that anymore in
our current uh in the new climate of the
modern era
um to just have that expectation anymore
I don't think it's logical
okay there's been too many benefits no
and that's the thing
I really don't like saying that like it
kind of puts like it makes me feel a
certain type of way but I understand it
because yeah it's like what incentive do
men have to marry you nowadays
yeah that right now there's no actual
incentive to me to marry because we
don't gain anything uh from the act of
marriage aside from you know telling the
world hey I love this person that's
pretty much the only incentive we have I
mean there are some like tax breaks and
stuff that we get to now take advantage
of but
it's a very limited scope whereas the
other side gets a lot more benefits and
upon the destruction of a marriage if
that occurs
once one side is massively that
destruction is almost completely
one-sided
um
so there's not really any incentive to
get married in the western world and and
mostly the modern world in general but
if we restore the legalities and bring
and bring back more balance uh for
instance uh one brought up the idea of
putting back into effect like uh taking
away a no-fault divorce I don't think
that's
necessary
instead separating fault and no fault
giving a kind of option and saying like
if you're taking no fault divorce you're
gonna get less back out of that you know
because you're walking away by choice
and having a separate one for fault
divorce where if something went
massively wrong that was out of your
control well now those other things that
you would do that would be open to you
in general now are now a thing so
because
fault divorce and no fault divorce and
you there's two different incentives
okay that's an interesting idea
that's an interesting idea because if
you want to walk away that's a choice
you should be able to make I mean if you
don't care or love about love a person
anymore being stuck with them is gonna
breed hostility but being incentivized
to do so because the option to just walk
away makes every single problem that
occurs in a relationship that much more
appealing it's there like you could just
oh cool uh you we had a fight today so
uh buy I'm Audi 5000 and that's a total
option but if you have both you know no
fault and fault divorce and if on the
no-fault one you're walking away doesn't
give you all the benefits of I don't
know alimony and stuff like that like
you walk away means I hope you can
support yourself and get your own job
right now if you're not working or
whatever or you have your own place you
don't get to take the house if you
didn't pay for it you know those
benefits that would come with a natural
a actual divorce now
then you're not incentivized to just
walk and it still leaves you the option
to do so and then there's also fault
divorce where if you are in an abusive
relationship and the dude just
beats the hell out of you you can go yo
he just knocked the crap out of me and
now the punishment has is able to fit
the crime essentially as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible